PANIC AT.
>> Bret: THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
STAND BY.
WE’LL BE BACK LATER IN THE SHOW.
ALSO BREAKING TONIGHT, TWO
AMERICANS ARE DEAD FOLLOWING A
ROCKET ATTACK ON A MILITARY BASE
IN IRAQ APPEARED IN NATIONAL
SECURITY CORRESPONDENT
JENNIFER GRIFFIN HAS A
DEVELOPING STORY FROM THE
PENTAGON.
>> A SENIOR U.S. MILITARY SOURCE
TELLS ME THAT TWO AMERICANS AND
ONE BRITISH SERVICE MEMBER WERE
KILLED WHEN 15 ROCKETS STRUCK
CAMP TASHI MILITARY BASE AT
30 MILES NORTH OF BAGHDAD, 11
MORE TROOPS HOUSED AT THE BASE
WERE INJURED IN TODAY’S ROCKET
ATTACK ACCORDING TO A
WELL-PLACED MILITARY SOURCE AND
AS OF TWO HOURS AGO, MEDICS WERE
STILL TREATING THE WOUNDED.
THIS REPRESENTS THE LARGEST
ATTACK TARGETING AMERICANS IN
IRAQ SINCE IRAN FIRED 16
BALLISTIC MISSILES AT BASES
HOUSING U.S. TROOPS IN EARLY
JANUARY, DAYS AFTER A U.S. DRONE
KILLED THE HEAD OF THE IRANIAN
FORCE, QASSEM SOLEIMANI.
ISIS DOESN’T HAVE THIS
CAPABILITY I’M TOLD BY AN
AMERICAN MILITARY SOURCE.
U.S. MILITARY OFFICIALS HAVE
WORRIED THAT IRAN WOULD TARGET
AMERICANS IN THE MIDDLE EAST TO
DEFLECT FROM THEIR OWN FAILED
ABILITY TO CONTAIN THE
CORONAVIRUS PANDEMIC AT HOME
WHICH IS ALREADY KILLED HUNDREDS
OF IRANIANS.